hemos estado hablando mucho de la
glucosa de este monosacáridos simple
llamado glucosa que es el bloque de
construcción de cosas como el glucógeno
el almidón y la quitina pero lo que
quiero hacer ahora en este vídeo es
ponerle un poco de atención a otro
monosacárido muy importante y este es la
fructosa que también puede ser conocido
como el azúcar de la fruta
ahora la fructosa solita como
monosacárido es el azúcar más dulce de
todos y bueno ahora vamos a ponernos a
comparar a estas dos moléculas y te
recomiendo que lo hagas por tu cuenta lo
primero que salta a la vista en esta
comparación que por cierto estas dos
moléculas es súper útil que las puedas
dibujar por tu cuenta
ok porque las vamos a ver muchísimas
veces tanto en biología como en química
y química orgánica pero bueno si
empezamos a comparar estas dos moléculas
podemos observar que las dos tienen 6
carbonos
porque hay entonces si nos fijamos en su
fórmula química las dos tienen seis
carbonos y luego si nos fijamos en los
hidrógenos podemos ver que las dos
tienen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
hidrógenos y 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
hidrógenos ok 12 hidrógenos y finalmente
las 2 también tienen 6 oxígenos ok 1 2 3
4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
y oxígeno así es que estos dos tienen
exactamente la misma fórmula química
pero pues son moléculas diferentes las
vías que son isómeros lo que hay de
hecho son y son menos estructurales sus
constituyentes el carbono hidrógeno y
oxígeno están enlazados de formas
diferentes haciendo que sean más o menos
estructurales y cuando nos ponemos a
observar a fondo estas moléculas hay
algo en particular que salta a la vista
por aquí la molécula de glucosa cuando
está en su forma de cadena lineal más
adelante vamos a hablar de cuando se
encuentra en su forma cíclica pero
cuando la glucosa la vemos de esta forma
podemos observar que la glucosa tiene un
grupo carbón y lo en el carbono número 1
ok porque los carbonos los empezamos a
numerar por aquí este es el carbono 1
3 4 5 6 y entonces la cadena lineal de
glucosa tiene un grupo carbon hilo en el
carbono número 1 mientras que en la
fructosa
este es el carbono 1 2
4 5 y 6
y en la fructosa el grupo carbón hilo se
encuentra en el carbono número 2
y recuerda el grupo carbón y lo es
simplemente un carbono con un doble
enlace a un oxígeno así es que la
fructosa tiene un grupo carbón hilo en
el carbono número 2 y esta es la gran
diferencia entre la glucosa y la
fructosa el lugar del grupo carbón hilo
porque si nos fijamos por aquí en todos
estos grupos hidroxilo
también tenemos por aquí tres grupos
hidroxilo del lado derecho un grupo
hidroxilo del lado izquierdo tres grupos
hidroxilo del lado derecho y un grupo
hidroxilo del lado izquierdo así es que
esta es la diferencia y bueno solo para
practicar un poco eso de la nomenclatura
de los grupos funcionales recordemos que
cuando estábamos estudiando la glucosa
vimos que si teníamos un grupo carbón y
lo que estaba al final de una cadena de
carbonos o sea que este carbono tiene el
doble enlace con el oxígeno tiene un
enlace con un hidrógeno y luego
un enlace con el resto de la cadena
vimos que le llamábamos a esto un grupo
funcional aldehído y hace que toda esta
molécula sea categorizada como un
aldehído ahora por aquí en la fructosa
el grupo carbón y lo ya no está al final
de la cadena de carbonos está en medio
de la cadena no está precisamente justo
a la mitad sino que está más bien en
medio tiene un enlace con otros dos
carbonos por lo que a este grupo
funcional les llamamos detona ok porque
este carbono está enlazado con otros dos
carbonos entonces la fructosa es un
acepto na
zona y ahora sí vamos a ver cómo se
puede convertir en una molécula cíclica
y como ya hemos visto antes
si estamos en un medio acuoso la forma
de cadena lineal y la forma cíclica
están en equilibrio y bueno recordemos
que lo que tenemos dibujado aquí no es
la única forma que puede tomar la
glucosa pero si la buscas en internet o
en un libro esta es la forma en la que
más comúnmente te la vas a encontrar de
hecho también es la forma que más
prevalece en la naturaleza ok en la
naturaleza casi siempre te vas a
encontrar con esta forma cíclica de la
glucosa donde tenemos 5 carbonos y un
oxígeno en el anillo mientras que la
forma cíclica típica de la fructosa es
un ciclo de 5 átomos cuatro de ellos
carbonos y uno de ellos oxígeno así es
que la glucosa puede formar un anillo de
seis miembros y siempre que tenemos una
estructura química un carbohidrato
que incluye a un anillo de seis miembros
cinco de los cuales son carbonos y uno
es oxígeno decimos que es una pira nosa
que es una estructura química que
contiene un anillo donde cinco son
carbonos y uno es oxígeno y ahora cuando
tenemos una estructura química que
incluye un anillo de 5 átomos en los
cuales cuatro son carbonos y 1 oxígeno a
esto le llamamos furanos ah
furanos ah y ahora la fructosa se puede
encontrar tanto en forma de furano ssa
como en forma de pila nosa aunque
típicamente la encontramos en forma de
furano ssa y la mayoría de las personas
cuando piensa en la forma cíclica de la
fructosa piensa en esta forma de aquí
furanos ah pero ahora podemos ponernos a
pensar en cómo se forma esta forma de
aquí sobre todo en comparación a como
sucedió en la glucosa aunque cuando
estábamos viendo la glucosa vimos que
generalmente hay un ataque núcleo físico
a este carbono de aquí aunque este es el
carbono número uno este es el carbono
número uno pero por acá en la fructosa
el carbono que tiene el doble enlace con
el oxígeno este carbono de aquí es el
carbono número 2 ok el carbono número 2
es al que le van a hacer el ataque
núcleo físico y en ambos casos si
queremos formar estos ciclos por aquí en
el carbono 5 tenemos a este grupo
hidroxilo tenemos por aquí el oxígeno y
el hidrógeno enlazados al carbono número
5 ok esto es el carbono 1 2
4 5 y 6 y este oxígeno es el que forma
el enlace con el carbono 1 el que forma
este enlace cuando estamos hablando de
la glucosa pero por acá en el caso de la
fructosa también es el oxígeno del grupo
hidroxilo del carbono 5 ok
este grupo hidroxilo de aquí es este
mismo de acá y este oxígeno de aquí es
el oxígeno que forma un enlace con el
carbono del grupo carbon hilo y cuando
esto sucede eso permite que uno de estos
dos enlaces del doble enlace que estos
dos electrones sean liberados del
carbono y se vayan a formar un enlace
con algún protón que esté flotando por
ahí que bueno este protón lo más
probable es que lo encontremos en alguna
molécula de idron eo y ahora exactamente
lo mismo sucedió por aquí con la glucosa
ok aquí uno de estos dos enlaces puede
irse
a formar un enlace con algún protón de
hidrógeno así es que esto es
esencialmente el mismo mecanismo ahora
la razón por la que aquí nos quedamos
con un anillo de cinco miembros cuatro
de los cuales son carbonos y por acá nos
quedamos con un anillo de seis miembros
de los cuales cinco son carbonos la
razón por la que obtenemos esta
diferencia es porque aquí el grupo
carbón y lo está en el carbono número
dos y aquí el carbón y lo está en el
carbono número uno ok por aquí el grupo
carbón y lo está más abajo en la cadena
de carbonos y es únicamente por eso por
lo que aquí obtenemos una forma
pentagonal y bueno como ya hemos dicho
antes la fructosa es el mundo sacar ido
más dulce lo que hay es el azúcar más
dulce de todos
cuando estamos hablando del azúcar de
mesa por ejemplo el azúcar que le
echaría a tu café oa un pastel esa
azúcar de mesa se llama sacarosa
a rosa y la sacarosa es un disacárido
compuesto de una molécula de glucosa y
una molécula de fructosa y la forma en
la que se da esa unión sigue siendo a
través de la síntesis por deshidratación
y en este proceso lo que sucede es que
este oxígeno de aquí del primer carbono
de la glucosa llega y forma un enlace
con el segundo carbono de la fructosa y
entonces este enlace de aquí estos
electrones de aquí podríamos incluso
pensar que pueden ir y formar un enlace
con algún otro protón de hidrógeno que
se encuentra flotando por ahí así es que
básicamente tenemos un carbono que tiene
un enlace con un oxígeno que está
enlazado con otro carbono y luego puede
llegar a alguna otra molécula de agua y
llevarse a este hidrógeno de aquí y
entonces nos quedaría estos enlaces con
los que ya estamos un poco
familiarizados estos enlaces glucose
cívicos que se dan en la síntesis por
decir
natación estos enlaces glucose cívicos
que son básicamente la razón por la cual
podemos empezar con monosacáridos y
crear dice queridos y si seguimos
formando cadenas más grandes
polisacáridos así es que en la sacarosa
lo que tenemos es una molécula de
glucosa que tiene un enlace glucose
cívico con una molécula de fructosa
y tal cual ésta es la sacarosa aunque
bueno para visualizarlo apropiadamente
lo que tendríamos que hacer es tomar
esta fructosa por aquí voltearla y
subirla por aquí y entonces ahora sí ya
tendríamos aquí una molécula de glucosa
con el enlace glucose y dico a la
molécula de fructosa